so people like to masturbate
they also like to eat twinkies and do
shots of jagermeister not typically all
at the same time but
if you had a rough week no one's gonna
judge judge
what these otherwise disparate pleasures
have in common
is that from a scientific perspective
we've been told they're all evolutionary
mistakes
so let's talk about masturbation
the orgasm is the best thing that can
happen to you
right evolution is reserving its biggest
carrot its biggest reward for the
behavior that it wants to reward the
most which is putting genes into the
next generation so this is typic the the
adaptive target of the orgasm is
reproductive sex
human beings being very clever primates
have figured out we can get this reward
other ways right so this is a classic
case of a brain hijack so this is one
type of evolutionary mistake where you
are getting a reward that you're not
supposed to get you're getting a reward
you're figuring out a way to trigger a
reward circuit that shouldn't be
triggered in the situation you're in
evolution designed this very powerful
positive reinforcement device and human
beings have figured out how to game the
system and other animals as well like
little rats pushing a lever to get
cocaine injections evolution's probably
kind of pissed off about this but it
it's not going to bother with it very
much because masturbation is a pretty
low cost behavior it's low cost and it's
also really not interfering at the end
of the day with the main objective we're
still doing plenty of reproductive sex
twinkies junk food in general is a
different type of evolutionary mistake
i'm going to call this an evolutionary
mismatch so this is a case where there
was an adaptive target but it doesn't
apply anymore so for most of our
evolutionary history
we food was a problem acquiring enough
food was a problem especially sweet
things and proteins fatty types of
things were a very patchy resource so
you get a lot of it all at once and then
you get nothing for a long time so
individuals who had a sweet tooth and
who liked fat and who would gorge on
this stuff when they had it had an
advantage this is a very adaptive trait
and for most of our evolutionary history
evolution is not going to care not
really be able to deal with this at all
because it's a very recent problem and
it's still pretty localized so there's
lots of places in the world where
getting enough calories is still a
challenge so evolution is not going to
worry about this mismatch problem too
much in the case of junk food
now when it comes to alcohol the
aegermeister shots
we've been told the standard story is
that it's a brain hijack that's the most
dominant scientific theory about why we
have a taste for alcohol we figured out
that consuming ethanol triggers this
reward network in our brain and like
that little rat pushing the lever we
just keep doing it that's the standard
story there are also various mismatch
theories floating around out there that
taste for alcohol allowed us to consume
liquid in a safe form when water was
contaminated there are several different
mismatch theories what i want to argue
tonight is none of these make sense none
of these can actually be an explanation
for an evolutionary explanation for why
we have a taste for alcohol and that's
because our taste for intoxication is
ancient costly and dangerous
as long as we've had writing
people have been complaining about the
dangers of alcohol the dangers of
alcoholism the dangers of social chaos
caused by excessive consumption we find
this in ancient egypt ancient china in
ancient sumer it's estimated that half
the grain production went to producing
beer
so they're taking half of their food and
turning it into liquid neurotoxins and
as you notice you know kings had to
decree that their subjects weren't
allowed to make more beer than a certain
amount because people want to turn it
into beer so very costly in terms of
social consequences and also just
materially costly economically costly
it's estimated that today
most households spend about a third of
their food and beverage budget on
alcohol and that's almost certainly an
underestimate because of black markets
and under reporting
and you may have not gotten the memo yet
about masturbation it doesn't make you
go blind
don't worry about it
what does make you go blind is alcohol
shots of jagermeister it can make you go
blind so it's very alcohol is very
damaging physiologically it causes liver
damage it raises your cancer risk from a
medical perspective there's really no
upside to alcohol and you can forget
about all this the french paradox
cholesterol stuff it's
it's bad for you from a biomedical
perspective alcohol is bad for you it's
a dangerous substance
in the tiny country that i live in now
about the size of
california 2014 is estimated that the
economic impact of alcohol abuse was
14.6 billion dollars that's probably
canadian dollars that's like ten dollars
u.s but it's still a lot of money um
fourteen thousand eight hundred deaths
eighty seven hundred hospital admissions
all these years of productive life loss
this is if this is an evolutionary
mistake it's an incredibly costly
evolutionary mistake it doesn't make
sense that there would not be some
pressure to fix this if all it was
was a cost
now sometimes it is the case that
evolution can't fix something so
evolution is constrained by certain
conditions so evolution can't act on a
variant that doesn't exist selection
pressure can't select for a genetic
variation that isn't out in the world
yet so it's possible that our
taste for alcohol is a mistake it's a
very costly ancient dangerous one but
genetic evolution just hasn't churned
out a variant yet that would fix the
problem that's one possibility there are
also various types of what's called path
dependence where evolution makes one
decision and then it's kind of stuck it
has to keep going down that path so that
could be part of the story too it's not
neither of those is possible in this
case because there are genetic and
cultural solutions to the problem of
intoxication the evolution could have
taken advantage of if it wanted to so
let's talk about the genetic one first
there is a set of two different
mutations in enzymes that have to do
with the processing of alcohol in the
body that lead to a syndrome that
sometimes called asian flushing syndrome
because it's most common in east asia
if you have this syndrome a couple sips
of alcohol your face turns red you start
to flush you feel nauseous drinking
alcohol is very unpleasant if you have
this this genetic condition
if alcohol were just a costly mistake
this is the solution to the problem this
is awesome it's actually so effective at
helping with drinking that a chemical
that reproduces the effects of this
genetic syndrome is used to treat
alcoholism because you just don't like
to drink so there is this genetic
solution out there and it's an ancient
one so it's estimated that this evolved
seven to ten thousand years ago
somewhere around present-day shanghai
but it just sits there this is present
distribution focused around its origin
spread a little bit to japan and korea
but it's pretty much sat there it's also
very interesting that
analogous mutations causing the same
effect have evolved at least twice
independently once in the middle east
and once in europe and also remain very
confined to limited populations
so this is the silver bullet to the
problem of our taste for alcohol and yet
it hasn't done anything it hasn't spread
very much that suggests that there's
there's more to the story here than just
some kind of evolutionary mistake
let's talk about cultural evolution
which is very powerful cultural
evolution can fix things very quickly
it's very good at responding to new
situations
how would cultural evolution deal with
the problem of a mistaken taste for
alcohol
pretty easy just tell people they can't
drink
right it's not it's not rocket science
um so prohibition we tend to think of
prohibition in the american context but
again anywhere
there have been human beings who can
write we have records of prohibition in
ancient china one of the earliest law
statutes that we have
decrees death to anyone who makes or
consumes alcohol
it didn't work it was about as
successful as american prohibition was
there are major world religions that are
based on prohibition one of their main
uh tenants is uh abstaining from things
that are intoxicating to the mind so
this the solution culturally is out
there and yet like that genetic solution
it just kind of sits there so this is
where alcohol is currently prohibited in
in part or in whole in the world it
looks a lot like that genetic map it it
didn't disappear the solution maintains
in our genetic and cultural repertoire
but it kind of sits there it doesn't
spread the way you would expect it to
spread if this was really only a problem
if there were only costs involved with
alcohol you would expect both this gene
complex and this cultural idea of just
prohibiting alcohol to spread very
quickly and it hasn't